ciao maryners e benvenuti in un nuovissimo video allora
solitamente quando ci sono loro due
assaggiamo cibi strani oggi faremo una
challenge nuovissima e cioè la challenge
di oggi è cose strane che solo il 10 per
cento no il 9 per cento no il 4 per cento
no noi vogliamo l'uno per cento quindi cose che neanche che solo ok non lo so il titolo cose
strane che solo l'1% di persone sa fare riesce a fare saremo l'1% di
quelle persone?
lo scopriamo subito la prima è toccarsi il
naso con la lingua la lingua col naso no
andrea è ufficialmente squalificato mi
dispiace sará per la prossima
toccarsi la lingua con il naso toccarsi il naso con la lingua vedi ma prima l'ho detto giusto? credo di si
nessuno no io una volta ci riuscivo
no tu no c'hai il rossetto
è colpa vostra ragazzi siete voi che mi avete obbligo a fare questo video pronti? leccarsi il
gomito é difficile comunque io ve l'avevo
detto lui riesce più o meno io
no ragazzi appare che mi spappolo tutta no ok lui è riuscito tu no
terza cosa strana guardare in due
direzioni differenti quindi un occhio
guarda dritto e l'altro guarda da
un'altra parte proviamo io so farlo ok
vediamo
ci sta stupendo tu? no provo io
come si fa? come fai scusami?
bisogna innanzitutto saper far così
ok e poi solo che lo fai mentre guardi
di lá cioé te lo sai fa mi sta venendo mal di testa
passiamo all'altra dividere le dita
cioè così ci riesco finalmente riesco a fare qualcosa
ne so uno anche più difficile cioé fai così e dividi le dita così io riesco fra oddio io no
ma tu non riuscivo nemmeno a farlo a mani chiuse dai peró questa positiva tutti
questo é impegnativo perché bisogna da un lato girare in senso orario
la nostra gambina ma allo stesso tempo
contemporaneamente disegnare un 6
dai si ce l'ho piú o meno fatta è un 6
variopinto peró va bene edoardo io allora
bene ovviamente meglio di salerno maraina
no é da quest'altra parte lui l'aveva girata
così no io ho fatto l'orario aspetta é piú bello il mio no è difficile raga mi fa
molto male il ginocchio
passiamo passato dai ragazzi
promossi arricciare la lingua io questo
non so farlo cioè mai riuscita mai ci
riuscirò tutte le sa fare fa vedere tu ma é genetica o lo sai fare o non lo sai fare
pronti con una mano tap tap sulla testa con l'altra dei cerchi
sulla pancia ma tutto ciò
contemporaneamente ok io so farlo allora vai tu che bravo fallo tu
beh peró é giusto
ok io non sono sicurissima deve essere veloce o piano questo dico eh come vuoi
questa é veramente difficile perché dobbiamo con le braccia ruotare ogni braccio in
direzione diversa quindi
contemporaneamente quindi questo va
avanti e questo va indietro giusto
peró la prima fallo tu fallo woooow
cavolo é difficile no ci devo riuscire ci devo riuscire
allungare le braccia e toccarsi i gomiti
quindi io sono quella scusate che si é
avvicinata di più eh diciamoci la verità
pollice appiccicato al polso questo io
credo
io devo dire che manca veramente
molto poco
anch'io no a te mancano 7 cm salerno come al solito vince a me manca veramente un millimetro
muovere le orecchie vedi come cavolo fa a muovere la fronte? la vedo immobile
proprio io più morte
di un morto ma a me avevano detto che bisogna ridere ma no no devi riuscire a tirare la fronte piegare la
falangetta dell'indice allora da così
andare dritto e affusolato ok ho vinto
incrociare le braccia e infilare la testa
qui dentro
fatto io pure
cioé non cosí tanto peró dai é entrata hai smollato le mani ok allora mentre edoardo continua a
provare perché ricordiamoci che la
speranza è l'ultima a morire
dichiariamo vincitore ufficiale di
questa challenge me stessa no vabbè dai
forse per questa volta possiamo fare uno
strappo vince andrea ma per poco come
insomma segno di riconoscimento per
questa vittoria deve fare tutti i gesti
che abbiamo fatto fino adesso
contemporaneamente fai un sei fateci
sapere qui sotto quante di queste cose
siete riusciti a fare sono sicura che
avrete fatto meglio di edoardo presente
perché ci vuole poco
allora noi ci siamo molto divertiti fateci sapere se é piaciuto anche a voi
e se ne volete altri vi mandiamo un bacio
con tutte due le mani ma in direzioni
diverse
ciao adoro
adesso alziamoci storti